did you have any idea how hard it is to
actually be no [ __ ] a man and I say
this and women go oh yeah dude as soon
as most women encounter any kind of
problem the first thing to do is turn to
a man their man their dad the mechanic
the police a man if you actually put a
woman from a problem and go no man
they're like oh sh whoa [ __ ] it's a
mental breakdown men day after day
especially if you're a high level man
let me make it something clear from my
life I'm talking from personal
experience I'm not just looking after me
I'm not just looking after my chick I'm
the guy and about 300 people's phone
books that they call when anything big
goes wrong you get arrested in Russia or
you need extraction from Ukraine you
need a million dollars whatever it is
Kazakhstan abduction they called me I'm
the first phone call I'm fixing 400
different lives I'm a Problem Solver
chicks can't fix [ __ ] any of this
[ __ ] right this is how hard it is to be
a man and it's amazing because Society
expects that of you but so do women